prosecutors have released three
harrowing videos made by parkland
Florida shooting suspect Nicholas Cruz
and one video the accused killer calmly
states is going to be the next school
shooter of 2018 prosecutors shouldn't
have much difficulty making their case
against him and these videos don't
really provide any new information or
answers but do they raise some big
questions why release them well media
wanted them media we're making all sorts
of Freedom of Information Act requests
and let's get some answer from retired
LAPD detective Mark Fuhrman and Andrew
[ __ ] who's 18 year old daughter
meadow was killed in the stone Douglass
High School shooting in February and
Andrew you were on radio today it was so
moving
you've done so much already to bring
sanity to this conversation about school
safety and so forth and you know our
viewers just you know our heart goes out
to you and thank you for being with us
tonight you had very poignant and
pointed words Andrew about this video
these videos being released I Laura I
really couldn't I didn't watch it I just
really I read the transcripts and
reading those transcripts made me sick
to my stomach just reading it so I'm
glad I didn't really look at the videos
but what bothered me was the the fame
aspect of it how even he knew he was
going to be glorified in the news and I
think that that's a big problem in this
country with the media using their names
and showing their pictures throughout on
the media throughout the country so I
think that we could learn a lot from
this as in this country and not really
show their names or their faces or in
the media I think it would make a
difference that's what they want and he
you're right he referenced that you're
gonna know who I am
mark Fuhrman premeditated murder in
Florida this this really kind of
explodes that like there's no way I
think they couldn't charge him now with
premeditated murder and that would mean
possibility of the death penalty but
you're very against the release of these
videos and tell us why well the the
release of the videos has no evidentiary
or inform a
in value whatsoever he is confessed and
he wants a life sentence in exchange for
no death penalty the media at large
requests because of Florida law of
discovery once discoveries made they can
ask pretty much anything that that the
defense attorney and the prosecutor have
so they do that but they obviously show
no responsibility by releasing this
because this information now in front of
every juror in the country not just
Florida is seeing something that makes a
death penalty case very difficult for
the prosecutors because now when you go
into that courtroom the jurors have all
seen this not only does he show
premeditation but he really kind of
argues against a mental defect he seems
completely in control of his planning
completely in control of the motive and
this is his manifesto Andrew you made
this point for me up yeah you made this
point in radio that the guy is like oh
he's insane
oh he has autism he doesn't have control
as faculty it's always crazy
well yeah may as maybe as mental he knew
what he was doing and you know Lord even
gets worse there's other videos my
daughter happened to get murdered in the
hallway so that that's gonna be the next
videos the media is going to be looking
at and they're gonna look to put that in
the media also on the third floor she
was shot nine times and that was uh
that's on the camera too so they'll be
looking for those videos next and that's
gonna be heart-wrenching
oh no and there's what they they were
trying to do is keep school shooting
video games going for the longest time
and thank goodness that's been shut down
andrew has been lobbying against that
mark I know you have strong feelings
about that as well parents are worried
about copycat killers who want Fame they
don't know they're not they're not
focused on what Andrews focused on how
to make these schools safe metal
detectors whatever we have to do to make
these schools safe there are practical
things that Texas is doing thank
goodness and other places mark final
word we Laura we have we have not just
elation on my website that people could
look at because now's the time for these
governors to act they need to look at
what Florida did what Governor Scott
helped get passed and look what we what
we're doing in Florida with the Senate
bill 702 six and they should be
proactive why should they be waiting for
another shooting because there's some
other sociopaths out there planning
another shooting so they shouldn't
proactive mark I think we should just
leave this with what mr. [ __ ] said
and here is outrage in his anger and his
self-righteous purpose to actually stop
these school shootings it could probably
be done if everybody really wanted it to
be thank you so much
much needed tonight